I purchased my rife back in 2021, but had to set it in for repair in February.
I paid for a hyper drive repair, which I'm not sure means they repaired it or replaced it.
Does this mean I now have the new crappy board you were talking about in the last Zoom call?
I don't remember who asked this question.
I don't remember if if you have an F117 or an F122,
I don't know the only way I would know if you have the good board or the bad board is to
open it up and look at it. But I don't know how I'd be able to tell you how to do that.
So I apologize, but I don't know the answer to that.
For those that may not know what I'm talking about, the older true rights,
the older F122s and the older F1s and all the F117s
have the Atelier Robin board in it. So it doesn't do the same things as the new Atelier Robin.
You can't run the 11th harmonic frequencies and things like that, but you at least have the old F121
board in the true rife machine. The newer true rife machines don't have that board. So
that's why we switched to the Atelier Robin or one of the reasons. So I don't know unless I opened
up your machine and looked at it. If they just did a hyper drive repair, then I doubt if they changed
the board. I want to think they would have charged to an awful lot of said money if they would have
changed out everything on it. So if it makes any difference, I have the F122 and it's already not
working again. Oh my goodness. So I certainly could take a look at it and we should probably talk.
I would need to know what is not working on it in order to tell you whether I think I can help you,
or you would have to get it back to true rife. I do know that I did talk to Jake at true rife recently
and he said that they're coming up with a whole new machine, which I would think if I was talking
to any other company, I would be excited about it, but talking to true rife, I'm not as excited
about it. And it makes me think that they're not going to service the F122s after this new machine
comes out. I don't know. I mean, maybe a little overly cynical in that case, but that's what happened
when they bought the company, they decided they're not going to serve service the F117s.
So I don't, I can't make a judge will call on what that company is going to do,
but it's because of things like that that we decided to make a switch. So if you call us, if you're
saying it's already not working again, let us know what isn't working and then I can tell you
if I think I can help you fix it or not. So